gensel Crosby and rust they look to set the tone
for the Penguins here as rust moves on in back
hands off the side of that that pass off a skate
in Center gobble up by Nick gorier he backed in
that go save M rebound ran paling digs it
free and then plays it back for San a good
job by his partner or at the time partner Nick
seeler to kind of cover for him as well seeler
continuing his strong play is Crosby poking one
in on goal off the turnover and the save made by
Hart fires right back the other way C to connect
it with a shot off iron conne planks one and the
game stays scoreless that transition game of the
Flyers again there a little sleepy good out left
pass here by forer to couturier this leads to
the chance for connecting and Ryan Graves took
care of that stall gets it again across the wrist
the line and his shot denied and it'll go to the
corner where hster jumps on it who and that's not
a coincidence they really operate that transition
game here's the bank play for a shot save made
by har as he was able to stop Riley Smith and
then a set play here for the penguin to dump
in Smith is there arrives on the scene first
and a great defensive play there by York Drew
o Conor has an empty cage to put it in good
defensive play there by York sealer a shot and
that's gloved and the Penguins will take the
face off in their own Zone a little bit of a
snoozer I'm not going to lie to you the last
20 obviously more excited there's Tipp Ito Deni
is he got free in front in a nice spot by Brink
the other end Brink sets up Tipp it no goal while
down a man over the last 10 games they've scored
two short headed goals and they're going to
try to get another one here connecting with
a short headed Breakaway save made the fire is
deny but they are always dangerous aren't they
anticipation and this is just great work four
flyers in one corner L air mails it and connect
is Off to the Races and watch how he tries to
go logo he that's a shot that Ki is so good at
didn't raise it enough it just wasn't able to get
above the pad but he's trying to get Pon ahead to
rush Jan one here and it's dangerous gensel and
Crosby gensel with a puck gensel to Crosby and he
scores sney Crosby is now the all-time leading
Point getter against the flyers in NHL history
and that's one of his easiest goals goal a couple
of games ago where sanheim is aggressive farbe
should be the safety valve for sanheim and he
gets caught Midway and when he does the puck
gets by him and that leads to an odd man situation
against cam York York not able to intercept chips
it for Crosby he is stopped the puck is kept
in by lank but then back Ed ahead lton Springs
connect the another short Ed Breakaway save again
to delovic he has the fly's number here early for
conne and here I mean just too loose for the for
the Penguins not recognizing danger when guys are
escaping The Zone and another Breakaway for conni
short-handed this looking line here it could be
because they just had a kill we'll have to keep an
eye on that as tippet moves in tippet all the way
around the shot and the save made again medovich
he leaves everyone in nice time per game now to
Tris San to talking about possibly cutting that
down a little bit here's Crosby the save made by
har feed by gel here moment ago to Crosby and
the right answer get it out the center L goes
across ice miss the line that was in skates and
that's a turnover and here's gel gensel the shot
save hard and the puck stays in play high off the
glass lot will just play it out to Setter for Nick
seeler this last chance for gensel that pass to
risina was the right idea to the weak side part
of the ice unfortunately RIS Lina not able to
handle it that led to this chance and another
good save for Hart in this so that'll get Nick
off the ice after that long ship and goes right
back to the line intercepted Forster nice little
play to connect knee in they go three on three
connected to Forster forer the shot he scores he
remains red hot and the Flyers have tied the game
and one Tyson hster put the puck in the back of
the net it's fun to watch and the feed by concy
Forester we talked so much about his shot and
he's able to Corral but watch where he is he's
inside the dots and when you're inside the dots
JJ you just give yourself a better angle to the
net his skates he was then checked by Le then
it's missed by York and zahna moves up with it
zahna the shot save made Carter har and sanine
still not able to get off the ice delorier did
though here's oconor out musling Brink centered
it in front bounes off of tippet back toward the
net comes back out sanim gets to it it's sanheim
who will move the puck and say I got to get this
down the ice at off to the bench and he does
just that 3 minutes and 24 second shift for
Travis sanheim that all started three shifts
ago for the Penguins their bottom six had two
consecutive shifts where they set up the Top
Line here's a turnover by tip of three on one
Smith to Malin Malin the move holds Waits and
then gets it back out to Graves cross I shot
and the Save By Heart and then connly missed
the puckets Ming in the slot shot save made
rebound Smith denied by heart hockey uh seven
consecutive shots for the Penguins before the
Chance by farby at the end of the period and
Carter Hart was spectacular I mean and he'll
start back with it makes the move Walker still
has the puck in across the line swerving to the
slot hands off at ch fair oh what a save and
the rebound put back underneath the Penguins
goenda as you mentioned I mean it's a two
onone Flyers have it cier with connecting
cier dropping it back here's York the shot and
that one glanced up off the glass stays in play
York yeah the Tang tried to Center forcer
another Play Breaking up a potential play
for the Penguins and now conni moves up C is
joining conne to cier the shot save made and
the puck bounces free and now it's Malin back the
other way watch forcer here defensively gets big
intercepts the play kills it and then out the
Flyers go Walker indirects it to connecting now
watch cier hangs on he's waiting for n delich to
slide over and then try to beat him far side but
the toe of n delovic more confident Atkinson
there might have tried a shot there's a shot
from the point save Atkinson digging away it
goes right over on the line but did not go in
how did that stay out Center and another look at
this near Miss for the Flyers Atkinson whacking
away that was well done to stay on side the
shot missed the target turnover cier holds to
Connected the shot anovich with this sa kept the
Play Alive a turnover there by Crosby behind the
net couturier finds connecting and then there
nalovic keeps it alive lot will play it ahead
he's got sanheim and sanheim couldn't get
it now he's got it with a game on his stick
sanheim off the post earlier in the ship
sanheim when he had gas in the tank this
opportunity keeps it on side the patience and
he had to D of It Came against Vegas and the
Flyers win the draw sanheim spins it ahead and
here's concy moving up with Cur two onone concy
with a puck KY HS 2 T8 he scores he now has
his second overtime game winner of the Year
fires win it as they knock off the Penguins two
to one in the extra session starts with the face
off win you win it automatic Rim you trap the
Peng two forwards Patience by connecti and the
Finish By cier what
again bu it's great to win in overtime